You know, scatter, gather, are they good names? And I was thinking alternative names are index copy to and index copy from. I'm not actually sure which I like the most, because index copy two versus from, the only thing you have to delineate the difference between those two is the fact that you're copying to an index versus copying from an index. Those are good names for it, by the way. I kept on saying integer sequence, yada, yada counts and offsets. Very nice names. Yeah.
你知道，scatter（分散）和gather（收集），这些名字好吗？我当时在想，替代名称可以是 index copy to（索引复制到）和 index copy from（索引从...复制）。我其实不太确定自己最喜欢哪一个，因为 index copy to 和 from，唯一能区分这两个操作的就是你是复制到一个索引，还是从一个索引复制。顺便说一下，这些名字起得很好。我一直在说整数序列、等等、计数和偏移量。非常好的名字。是的。
Not names that I picked, names that the A I picked. Let us all bow down to the machine gods that rule us. Yeah, the machine gods that rule us where we can't even find the chat that I had two days ago. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 257 recorded on September 23rd, 2025. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host, Bryce, we record live. one day before NDC Tech Town in Kongsburg, Norway. In today's episode, we continue our discussion of the replicate algorithm as well as scatter, gather, run-length decode, and more.
不是我选的名字，是人工智能选的名字。让我们向统治我们的机器神低头吧。是的，统治我们的机器神，我们甚至找不到两天前的那次聊天记录。欢迎来到 ADSP 播客，第 257 集，录制于 2025 年 9 月 23 日。我是 Connor，今天和我的联合主持人 Bryce 一起进行现场录制。地点在挪威孔斯贝格的 NDC Tech Town 大会前一天。在今天的节目中，我们将继续讨论 replicate（复制）算法，以及 scatter、gather、游程解码（run-length decode）等等。
All right, folks, we're back. It's been a minute. Last time you heard from us, where were we, Bryce? We were on the... He doesn't remember. He's... You were in the car? No, that was two episodes ago, Bryce.
好了，各位，我们回来了。有一会儿没见了。上次你们听到我们的声音时，我们在哪里，Bryce？我们在……他不记得了。他……你在车里吗？不，那是两集之前的事了，Bryce。
God. Admittedly, it's been a long two days for us. We just finished two. No one can hear you right now. You forgot how this worked, buddy. You got to wait until the mic is in front of your mouth. Last time we talked to you, we were walking on the streets of Copenhagen. I think we just left you when we were about to get ice cream.
天哪。诚然，对我们来说这两天过得很漫长。我们刚结束两场……现在没人能听到你说话。你忘了这玩意儿怎么用了，伙计。你得等麦克风放到嘴边才行。上次我们和你交谈时，我们正走在哥本哈根的街头。我想我们离开你的时候，正准备去买冰淇淋。
Let's first do a review of the Copenhagen soft serve. Yeah, you got soft serve as well. How was it, Bryce? Well, I got to say. given that I didn't remember it until a moment ago. I don't think it was the most memorable thing. But I did have a wonderful dinner at this restaurant here called Nula, which is...
我们先来回顾一下哥本哈根的软冰淇淋。是的，你也吃了软冰淇淋。味道怎么样，Bryce？嗯，我得说，鉴于我刚才才想起来，我觉得它不是最令人难忘的东西。但我确实在这家叫 Nula 的餐厅吃了一顿很棒的晚餐，那是……
Yeah, the Indian place. The Indian place, who it's a master chef winner, or she came in third or whatever for master chef. But it was an excellent meal, and Connor bailed out on me. Connor and Ashwin bailed out on me after two days of training, we taught people to coup to C++,
是的，那家印度餐厅。那家印度餐厅，它的主厨是《厨艺大师》的获胜者，或者她是第三名之类的。但那顿饭非常棒，Connor 抛弃了我。Connor 和 Ashwin 在两天的培训后抛弃了我，我们教人们使用 CUDA C++，
we taught people to C++, we taught people the coup to Python. Now I've got to give one more talk, and then I get to go home. See, I apologize on behalf of Bryce, folks. He doesn't understand how podcasting works. He just started explaining to you the meal he had tonight, and it is now officially 48 hours later.
我们教人们使用 CUDA C++，我们教人们使用 CUDA Python。现在我还要再做一个演讲，然后我就可以回家了。看，我代表 Bryce 向大家道歉，伙计们。他不明白播客是怎么运作的。他刚才开始向你们解释他今晚吃的饭，而现在距离那时已经整整 48 小时了。
We're in a different country. We're in a different city. What? No, last. last time we recorded was uh actually that's true it's been 72 hours last time we recorded was Saturday we were traveling on Sunday guess what folks I mean let's go chronologically so the last we left you we were having ice cream we went to sleep we woke up we were in transit what you want to tell them about the train I too wait we're not at the train yet we because what happened
我们在不同的国家。我们在不同的城市。什么？不，上次……上次我们录音是……其实那是真的，已经过去 72 小时了，上次录音是周六，我们周日一直在赶路。猜猜怎么着，伙计们，我们按时间顺序来吧。上次离开你们时，我们正在吃冰淇淋，然后去睡觉，醒来后就在路上了。你想告诉他们关于火车的事吗？我……等等，我们还没到火车那儿，因为发生了什么……
before the train we were on a plane we were on a plane and who did we run into on the plane We ran into Jason Turner on the plane. Not just Jason. Jason and his partner, Jen. It was lovely to see him. Haven't seen them in, I think, close to a year. And more important, Bryce is just chopping out the bit to get this point. More importantly, Connor was napping on the plane, and I got photos, folks.
在火车之前，我们在飞机上。我们在飞机上，我们在飞机上遇到了谁？我们在飞机上遇到了 Jason Turner。不仅仅是 Jason。还有 Jason 和他的伴侣 Jen。见到他真好。我想我们有快一年没见他们了。更重要的是，Bryce 正急不可耐地想说这一点。更重要的是，Connor 在飞机上打盹，我拍了照片，伙计们。
And they're going all over the Internet. I'm allowed to nap, folks. I was tired. It, uh, I was tired. It was, it was a 10.55 flight. There was no reason to be tired. actually folks there was a reason to be tired i had to make a game time decision did i run in copenhagen at a very early hour because we needed to leave i believe it was at 830 to be at the
而且这些照片正在互联网上传播。我被允许打盹，伙计们。我很累。那是……那是 10 点 55 分的航班。没理由不累。其实伙计们，是有理由累的。我必须做一个临时的决定：我是否要在哥本哈根很早的时候去跑步，因为我们需要离开，我相信是 8 点 30 分，为了 9 点到达
airport at 9 which means in order to do a 10 to 15k run i've got to be up a hell of early and i think i woke up at what was it 630 or something like that in order to be back so it was either do that or run when i get to kongsberg which was going to be at like 3 p.m. in the afternoon and I didn't know it was going to be cold. I made the right decision for the wrong reasons. I made the right decision because I thought Copenhagen would be easier to run in. I'd be tired. It's been freezing here, folks.
机场，这意味着为了跑 10 到 15 公里，我必须起得非常早。我想我是 6 点 30 分左右醒的，为了赶回来。所以要么那样做，要么等我到了孔斯贝格再跑，那时已经是下午 3 点了，而且我不知道那里会很冷。我因为错误的原因做出了正确的决定。我做出正确的决定是因为我以为在哥本哈根跑会更容易。我会很累。这里一直冷得要命，伙计们。
Guess what? I did not run this morning. Today is Tuesday. Yesterday I woke up and I spent 45 minutes coercing myself to get out of bed and run. And I did. It was two degrees for the American folks. That's like 36 Fahrenheit or something. I couldn't feel my hands the whole run.
你猜怎么着？我今天早上没跑。今天是周二。昨天我醒来，花了 45 分钟说服自己起床去跑步。我确实去了。对于美国人来说，那是 2 摄氏度。大概是 36 华氏度左右。整个跑步过程中我的手都冻僵了。
And today it was even colder. It was zero. I know what that is in Fahrenheit. That's 32. I couldn't do it. I couldn't force myself to get out of bed. And I don't have, you're thinking, why don't just throw on a fleece?
今天更冷。是 0 度。我知道华氏度是多少。那是 32 度。我做不到。我无法强迫自己起床。而且我没有……你可能会想，为什么不直接套上一件抓绒衣？
I didn't bring a fleece. I brought shorts, a hoodie, that's it. Anyway, so we ran into Jason. We had a lovely visit with them on the train until, what happened, Bryce? Well, we seem to be cursed for our train luck this trip because once again, dear listener, we got on a train.
我没带抓绒衣。我只带了短裤和一件连帽衫，就这些。总之，我们遇到了 Jason。我们在火车上和他们聊得很开心，直到……发生了什么，Bryce？嗯，我们这次旅行的火车运势似乎被诅咒了，因为亲爱的听众，我们又一次上了火车。
This was actually, wait, both times that we got on a train together. two for two both times we got on a train together something happened with the train the previous train got completely cancelled but this train didn't get entirely cancelled but we went somewhere and then they started speaking in the uh the norwegian and then uh then the signs changed and the our stop disappeared from the little display monitor and then a guy came through and asked for our tickets and he said oh well this train's heading in the opposite direction now because there's a track closure and you got to get off the train and something something, something about a bus and we got off and we went and walked over with other people and it looked like there was going to be a bus but then the bus wasn't going to take us
这其实是……等等，我们两次一起坐火车。两次都中招了。两次我们一起坐火车，火车都出了点事。之前的火车完全取消了，但这趟火车没有完全取消，但我们开到某个地方，然后他们开始用挪威语广播，然后标志变了，我们的站点从显示屏上消失了，然后一个人走过来查票，他说：“哦，这趟火车现在往相反方向开，因为轨道关闭了，你们得下车，然后……关于巴士的事……”我们下了车，和其他人一起走过去，看起来会有巴士，但那辆巴士不会带我们
to the final destination. The bus was just going to take us around the train closure, the track closure and I was like, I'm not having enough of this so we got a very expensive Uber. Well, not a very, well, depending on your frame of reference an expensive Uber that we took directly to Kongsburg, the city of
去最终目的地。巴士只是带我们绕过火车停运的路段，我当时想，我受够了，所以我们叫了一辆非常昂贵的 Uber。嗯，也不是非常……好吧，取决于你的参考系，是一辆昂贵的 Uber，我们直接坐到了孔斯贝格，这座城市……
Honesburg. That's not really a city. I don't know what the population is, but I don't think it gets to be called the city. It is a sleepy little town. It is. It's a sleepy little town. It is. It's a sleepy buddy, buddy. I got to
孔斯贝格。那其实不算城市。我不知道人口是多少，但我觉得它称不上城市。它是一个安静的小镇。确实。它是一个安静的小镇。确实是，伙计，伙计。我得
tell you, the restaurant that I had dinner at tonight, one of the folks who was in our training today, he's Norwegian, he's from this town. His parents own the building that the restaurant is in. the population Yes, that's a sleepy little town
告诉你，我今晚吃晚餐的那家餐厅，今天参加我们培训的人之一，他是挪威人，他就是这个镇上的人。他父母拥有那家餐厅所在的建筑。人口……是的，那是一个安静的小镇。
You don't get to be a city Until you're more than 50,000 population I'm sorry But the town of Konsorg But the place where we had dinner The guy Literally had dinner with the person Who owns the building that the restaurant was in
你不能被称为城市，除非人口超过 5 万。抱歉，但是孔斯贝格镇……但是我们吃晚餐的地方，那个人……我真的和拥有那家餐厅所在建筑的人一起吃了晚餐。
Because it's a little town Everybody knows everybody Anyways We got here And then we had to do an eight-hour training On Monday On Kuta C++ Which Connor
因为这是一个小镇，每个人都认识每个人。总之，我们到了这里。然后我们必须在周一进行八小时的培训，关于 CUDA C++，Connor
delivered about 40, 50% of, I delivered the rest of it. And then... It would have been 50-50 if you hadn't gone over by half an hour. It would have been 50-50 if I hadn't gone over by half an hour. I did not go over by half an hour. I went over by about 15 minutes and nobody complained. We got great... It was 30.
讲了大约 40% 到 50%，剩下的我讲了。然后……如果你没有超时半小时，本来会是 50-50 的。如果你没有超时半小时，本来会是 50-50 的。我没有超时半小时。我只超时了大约 15 分钟，没人抱怨。我们得到了很棒的……是 30 分钟。
We got great feedback. The training in 15 minutes, but then you proceeded to give a bunch of references and blah, blah, blah. People go to left one over, and then everybody was happy. I got great feedback. We had lots of lovely people there. and then today we did a coup de python training which I gave about half of and my colleague, our colleague Ashran gave about
我们得到了很棒的反馈。培训超时了 15 分钟，但随后你继续给出了一堆参考资料，等等等等。人们离开了一个，然后每个人都很开心。我得到了很棒的反馈。我们在那里有很多可爱的人。然后今天我们进行了 CUDA Python 培训，我讲了一半，我的同事，我们的同事 Ashwin 讲了
half of it all went great. It was excellent. It was wonderful. Now I got one more talk just one more tomorrow because tomorrow is the open of NDC Tech Town which is I'm learning the people tell me I didn't realize it's not actually a C++ plus conference it's an embedded
剩下的一半，一切都很顺利。非常出色。非常棒。现在我还有一个演讲，明天只有一个，因为明天是 NDC Tech Town 的开幕式，我正在了解，人们告诉我，我没意识到这其实不是一个 C++ 大会，而是一个嵌入式
conference. It seems like different people have different ideas about what this conference is about but I haven't been to this conference before. Don't you know? I mean, I didn't go to that many talks. I just talked to a lot of people. So wait, you've been to, when was the last time you were in NDC? Wait, wait, wait, just wait for me to ask because nobody can hear what you're saying. When was the last time you were in NDC Tech Town and give us your review of that last edition that you were here for?
大会。看起来不同的人对这个大会的主题有不同的看法，但我以前没参加过这个大会。你不知道吗？我是说，我没参加过那么多讲座。我只是和很多人聊过。等等，你上次参加 NDC 是什么时候？等等，等等，等我问，因为没人能听到你在说什么。你上次参加 NDC Tech Town 是什么时候？给我们评价一下你上次参加的那届吧。
I'm assuming it was pre-pendemic, but you can tell us. I was here last year. It was very nice, lovely people. Yeah, yeah, I was here last. Yeah, last year, very lovely. I do recall talking to lots of people who worked on interesting devices, like people from the company that makes remarkable, the little liquid paper tablet thingy were here,
我假设是在疫情前，但你可以告诉我们。我去年来过。非常好，可爱的人们。是的，是的，我去年来过。是的，去年，非常可爱。我确实记得和很多从事有趣设备工作的人交谈，比如制造 Remarkable 的公司的人，那个小小的电子纸平板电脑，他们就在这里，
and there were a couple other people, like somebody who worked in like some sort of deep sea vehicle. So lots of people who worked on things that now I'm realizing are all embedded things. But at the time, I just thought they were very cool things. You know that I saw Chandler earlier. Which Chandler? Chandruth. he's not on the schedule but and also too No you didn't see Chan I haven't seen Chandler in so long
还有其他几个人，比如有人在某种深海航行器工作。所以很多人从事的工作现在我意识到都是嵌入式的东西。但在当时，我只是觉得它们是非常酷的东西。你知道我早些时候看到 Chandler 了吗？哪个 Chandler？Chandruth。他不在日程表上，而且……不，你没看到 Chandler。我好久没见 Chandler 了。
No one can hear what I'm saying But I did definitely see Unless if Chandler Coincidentally happens to be in the city of Kansber It was definitely him It was definitely him He had a sharp haircut He always has a sharp haircut
没人能听到我在说什么。但我确实看到了。除非 Chandler 巧合地出现在孔斯贝格市。那绝对是他。那绝对是他。他剪了个利落的发型。他总是留着利落的发型。
He's always very nicely dressed And he had a mask on It was definitely I mean I'm saying definitely But as a former actuary I should take a step back I'm 97% sure.
他总是穿得很得体。而且他戴着口罩。那绝对是……我是说绝对是，但作为一名前精算师，我应该退一步。我有 97% 的把握。
That means that there's a 3-100 chance that I think I'm wrong. I'm very confident Chandler's here, even though he's not speaking. And what was I also going to say? Techtown, embedded, 24, Jetson, embedded, your talks tomorrow. All right, well, let's transition. You just heard a record scratch. I can't remember what the second point I had to make was... That's because...
这意味着有 3% 的几率我认为我错了。我非常确信 Chandler 在这里，尽管他没有发言。我还要说什么来着？Techtown，嵌入式，24，Jetson，嵌入式，你明天的演讲。好吧，让我们转换话题。你刚才听到了唱片刮擦声。我不记得我要说的第二个点是什么了……那是因为……
Connor's turning into an old man. Well, I mean, I'm just catching up with you, because you already an old man. That is true. Anyways, our plan is to record tomorrow night. We already told you about this on Saturday. You're hearing it a week apart. But it is now Tuesday.
Connor 正在变成一个老头子。好吧，我是说，我只是在赶上你，因为你已经是老头子了。那是真的。总之，我们的计划是明晚录音。我们周六已经告诉过你们了。你们隔了一周才听到。但现在是周二。
The conference starts tomorrow. And tomorrow night is the NDC social after the first day of the conference. We're going to be interviewing folks. But right now, we are following us. up our conversation, which I butchered by saying... Are you kidding me?
大会明天开始。明晚是大会第一天后的 NDC 社交活动。我们将采访一些人。但现在，我们正在跟进我们的对话，我把它搞砸了，因为我说……你在开玩笑吗？
Before Sean came on and talked about how he crashed the Porsche, I consider the pizza to Google story by Chandler. I mean, that was the best we had. I think to this day, too, it's probably the most inspiring because as good as the Sean Parent crashing the Porsche story is,
在 Sean 上台谈论他如何撞毁保时捷之前，我考虑过 Chandler 的“披萨到谷歌”的故事。我是说，那是我们听过最好的故事。我认为直到今天，它可能也是最鼓舞人心的，因为尽管 Sean Parent 撞毁保时捷的故事很棒，
that's just an amazing story. You're not inspiring anyone to, like, card and end up at a, you know... I think of I heard that story. I'm being inspired to my whole. Anyway, so we're going to be interviewing folks tomorrow, but now we're going to follow up our conversation to replicate, of which you've listened to already, like, a week or two
那只是一个惊人的故事。你并没有激励任何人去……我想如果我听到了那个故事。我被激励去……总之，所以我们明天会采访一些人，但现在我们要跟进关于 replicate 的对话，你们已经听过了，大概是一两周前，或者可能是一周前，刚刚一周前。我说 scatter，scatter，scatter，scatter，但我编辑了它。还没。现在的 Connor 还没编辑它。你为什么要说 scatter，scatter，scatter？因为记得吗，我向你解释过 permutation iterator（置换迭代器）是 scatter 算法的惰性版本？你为什么要告诉听众？
ago, or maybe it was a week ago, just a week ago now. And I said scatter, scatter, scatter, scatter, but then I edited it. Not yet. Current Connor has not edited it. Why are you saying scatter, scatter, scatter. Because remember, I explained to you that the permutation iterator was the lazy version of the scatter algorithm? Why are you telling the listener?
哦，因为我会保留几个。我必须让他们知道，因为他们会注意到 scatter 那安静、有回声的房间与哥本哈根嘈杂街道的对比。我没法……Gather，是的，Scatter 对比 Gather。没关系。不，我现在永远不会忘记了。我永远不会忘记 Gather 是算法版本。
Oh, because I will keep a couple in. I have to let them know because they're going to notice the quiet, echoy room of scatter versus the noisy streets of Copenhagen. There's no way I can... Of Gather, yeah, Scatter versus Gather. It's all right. No, I will never forget now. I will never forget the Gather is the algorithm version.
问题是，为什么我们不把算法和迭代器叫同一个名字呢？Gather，gather 迭代器。Sequence，sequence 迭代器。或者 counting，counting。为什么我们不把它们命名为一样呢？我不知道。没人知道。但总之，Bryce 有时间思考如何实现这个算法，
The problem is, why don't we just call algorithm and iterators the same thing? Gather, gather iterator. Sequence, sequence iterator. Or counting, counting. Why don't we just name them the same, you know? It's beyond me. Nobody knows. But anyways, Bryce has had some time to think about how to implement this algorithm,
我也去看过了，有很多令人兴奋的事情可以讨论。我们要把麦克风交回给 Bryce。你得先来，因为在两天的培训和花几个小时试图帮助 NVIDIA 客户调试一些奇怪的问题之后。我必须把如何单次传递实现 replicate 的上下文重新加载回来。
and I have gone and taken a look, and there's lots of exciting things to talk about it. We're going to hand the mic back to Bryce. You're going to have to go first, because after two days of training and just spending a couple hours with an NVIDIA customer trying to do. bug some weird problem. I have to page the context of how to implement, replicate in a single pass back in.
好吧，我可以先聊一点。记得我们讨论过整数重载，它是惰性的且简单的。现在我们讨论的是数组重载，它接受一个整数数组，其长度对应于我们
All right, well, I can chat a little bit first. Remember, we talked about the integer overload, which is lazy and easy. And now we're talking about the array overload, which takes an array of integers that corresponds in length to the length of our
序列的长度，你基本上想把每个对应的元素复制该元素或对应整数所指定的次数。正如我在上一集提到的，如果你有 ABC 和 123，你最终会得到 A, B, B, CCC。正如 Bryce 刚才在麦克风外提到的，你可能注意到了，也可能没注意到。它实际上是一个游程解码，问题是，讨论的是，如何在并行中实现这一点。如果我们看当前的实现，它显然会改变，这是一个实验性库，伙计们，所以一切变化都非常快。我想我有五个内核。五个内核，Bryce。这不难超越。这绝对太多了，而且不难超越。是的，所以我现在想起了所有
sequence and you want to basically copy each of the corresponding elements the number of times of the element or the integer that corresponds to that element. So as I mentioned in the last episode, if you have ABC and 123, you end up with A, B, B, CCC. As Bryce just mentioned off mic, you may have picked it up, you may have not. It is effectively a run-length decode and the question is, and the discussion is, how to implement this in parallel. If we look at the current implementation, which obviously will change, it's an experimental library, folks, so everything changes very quickly. I think I had five kernels. Five kernels, Bryce. That's not hard to beat. It's definitely too many, and it's not too hard to beat. Yeah, so now I'm remembering all
上下文。是的，就像我在飞机上做这个的时候。当 Connor 打盹时，我在手机的记事本上疯狂地写代码。正如我经常做的那样。我想我可能只是读给你听一些我在飞机上写的文档里的笔记。好吧，所以按块来看，如果我们考虑这个问题，让我们把这个问题分成一堆块，这就是我们想要做的并行化。
the context. Yeah, like I was working on this when we were on the plane. When Connor was napping, I was furiously coding on my notepad on my phone. as I often do. I think I may just read you some of my notes from this document that I wrote on the plane. All right, so per block, if we think about this problem, let's divide this problem up into a bunch of blocks, which is what we want to do to paralyzes.
我们需要能够把这个问题细分成一堆块。所以假设对于每一组线程，每一组线程我们都有一个固定的值和计数的输入对，然后我们想要输出一个固定的 k 个值，这就是我们今天拥有的设施，CUB 可以做到这一点，它是固定大小的输入和固定大小的输出。问题在于你会遇到两种情况之一。要么，K 被少于 N 个输入超过了。所以你的固定大小输出，你在处理完所有输入对之前就耗尽了输出。
We need to be able to subdivide this problem up into a bunch of blocks. So let's assume that for each block of threads, each group of threads we've got a fixed input of in pairs of value and count and then we want to out to do a fixed output of k values um and that's like the the facility that we have today and cub can can do that it is a fixed size input and a fixed size output um the problem with that is you end up with having one of two cases. Either one, K is exceeded by less than N inputs. So your fixed-size output, you exhaust your output
如果那样的话，我们如何在不引入负载不平衡的情况下处理剩余的 N 个输入？另一种情况是所有 N 个输入都耗尽了，但我们产生的输出少于 K 个。如果那样的话，输出中就会出现间隙。所以这个算法不像你希望的那样直接进行单次传递。
before you get through all of your input pairs. And if that's the case, then how do we process the remaining N inputs without introducing load and balance? The other case is where all in inputs are exhausted but we've produced less than K outputs. And if that's the case, then you end up with gaps in the output. And so this algorithm is just not as straightforward to do single pass as you might wish.
我想如果我去看我的 ChatGPT 历史记录，它相当直接。哦，天哪，从那以后有很多 ChatGPT 查询。不，在哪里……好吧，好吧。你拿着这个一会儿。好吧，伙计们。我不确定我现在该说什么。Bryce 只是在查看他和 ChatGPT 的聊天记录。
I think if I go to my chat GPT history, it is pretty straightforward. Oh, God, there's been a lot of chat GPT queries since. No, where is... Okay, all right. You hold this for a second. All right, folks. I'm not sure what I'm supposed to say right now. Bryce is just looking through the history of his chats with chat, EBT.
既然 Bryce 不注意，我就带你们过一遍我实现的算法，它显然会被替换，因为它有五个内核。如果我没记错的话，它从整数序列上的加法扫描（plus scan）开始，代表我们需要复制事物的次数，这引导我们找到解码序列中每个值序列的起始位置，然后我做了一个 scatter-if，
Seeing as Bryce is not paying attention, I'll just walk you through the algorithm that I had implemented, which will clearly be replaced because it's five kernels. If I recall from memory, it starts off with a plus scan on the integer sequence, representing the number of times we have to copy things and that leads us to the starting positions of each of the sequences of values in our decoded sequence then I do a scatter if which
我们需要讨论一下命名，因为我们在上一集没讨论过。我们从冰淇淋到走回酒店进行了激烈的讨论，Bryce 想录音，我说不不不，我们下次再谈。这就是 scatter 和 gather 的命名，这也是我把 scatter 说成 gather 的部分原因，因为 gather 是……我们问了 ChatGPT 这个，或者等等，你确实录了一个关于 yeet 对比 yonk 的小录音，也许……也许我现在会剪进去。最幽默的一个是 yit 和 yonk，然后 Bryce 觉得那太搞笑了。
we need to talk about to the naming because we didn't talk about that on the last episode we had a big discussion from the ice cream to the walk home the hotel and Bryce wanted to record and I said no no no we'll talk about this next time and it's the naming of scatter and gather which is part of the reason that I I messed up saying scatter when I should have been saying gather because gather is and we asked chat to be t this or actually wait you did record a mini recording of the yeat versus yonk which maybe maybe I'll cut in right now the top humorous one was yit and yonk and then Bryce thought that was hilarious
那就是我们应该叫它的名字。但我的回应是，好吧，那没有任何意义，因为 yeet 的意思是，比如，删除，摆脱，扔掉，你知道吗？他们说 yeet 它意味着摆脱它。而那不是 Scatter 在做的事情。所以，从语义上讲，它与实际的语义没有任何关系。我相信你特别说过，yeet 在语义上与实际操作没有任何关系。
and that's what we should call it. But my response was, well, that doesn't make any sense because yeat means to, like, delete, to get rid of, to toss it, you know? And they say, yeat it means get rid of it. And that's not what Scatter's doing. So, semantically, it has nothing to do with the actual semantic. I believe you said specifically, yeet semantically has nothing to do with the actual operation.
是的，是的，类似那样。但最好的建议，在我看来，因为我实际上想过 scatter to 和 gather from，我当时想的是 gather，因为你是从一个索引收集，然后复制到一个输出，但 scatter 是从一个输入分散到一个输出索引，所以 gather 是我想要达到的算法，但你知道 scatter gather，它们是好名字吗？这个想法是你基本上……我当时在想替代名称是 index copy to 和 index copy from。我其实不太确定自己最喜欢哪一个，因为 index copy to 和 from。唯一能区分这两个操作的就是你是复制到一个索引，还是从一个索引复制。
Yeah, yeah, something like that. But the best suggestion, in my opinion, because I had actually thought about scatter to and gather from where I was thinking of gather because you're gathering from an index and then copying to an output but scatter is scattering from an input to an output index and so gather is the algorithm I was reaching for but you know scatter gather are they good names the idea that you basically, and I was thinking alternative names are index copy to and index copy from. I'm not actually sure which I like the most because index copy two versus from. The only thing you have to delineate the difference between those two is the fact that you're copying to an index versus copying from an index.
总之，有点令人困惑。scatter to 的一个属性是，你只能说，scatter to 的最大索引数是你输入序列的长度，而 gather 没有那个属性。gather from，你可以多次从同一个索引收集，因此你最终得到的输出序列可能比输入序列长。从技术上讲，scatter to 的输出序列可能更长，但你最终进行的复制次数小于或等于
Anyways, a little bit confusing. And one of the properties of a scatter two is that you can only say, scatter to the maximum number of indexes you can scatter to is the length of your input sequence whereas gather does not have that property gather from you can gather from the same index multiple times and therefore you can end up with an output sequence that is longer than the input sequence and technically like the output sequence from scatter two could be longer but the number of copies that you'll end up doing is less than or equal to
你拥有的输入序列。总之，scatter to，gather from，index copy to，index copy from，重点是，我有一个 scatter-if，你把值从输入序列分散
the input sequence that you have. Anyways, scatter two, gather from, index copy to, index copy from, and the point is, I had a scatter if, where you are scattering the value from your input sequence
到整数，如果它等于一个计数迭代器。所以你最终得到加法扫描后的累积和，那就是你想复制每个解码序列的第一个值的地方。所以你做一个 scatter-if，如果计数迭代器等于加法扫描整数中的一个值。
to the integer if it equals a counting iterator. So you end up with the cumulative sums from your plus scan on the integers, and that's where you want to copy the first value of each decoded sequence. And so you do a scatter-if the counting iterator equals one of the values in your plus-scanned integers.
所以你最终在每个解码序列或子序列的开头得到一个值。然后在那之后，你做一个最大值扫描（max scan）来基本上把那个值复制到子序列的其余部分。然后我想在那之后还有一个内核。但那是最大值扫描，scatter-if，加法扫描。我是说，技术上我只提到了三个内核。但我看我的算法时数了五个。总之，交给你了，Bryce。
And so you end up with a value at the beginning of each decoded sequence or sub-sequence. And then after that, you do a max scan to basically copy that. value to the rest of the sub-sequence. And then I think there's one other kernel at the end of that. But that is a Mac scan, a scatter-if, a plus scan. I mean, technically I only mentioned three kernels there. But I counted five when I looked at my algorithm. Anyways, over to you, Bryce.
你高兴我刚才随机聊了七分钟吗？因为我有一个 ChatGPT 聊天记录，我知道它在那里，但当我……我无法在手机列表中搜索到它，我只是得到，你知道，手机上的错误错误错误，我试过
Are you glad that I just randomly talked for like seven minutes? Because I had a chat GPT chat. chat that I knew was there but when I I could not find it in the list of my phone when I search for it I just get you know error error error on the phone I tried
我们在考虑它，我清除了手机上的缓存，我打开了甲板，我找不到它。我知道它在那里，最终我打开了浏览器，我在浏览器里搜索它，第一次给我一个错误，第二次它就弹出来了，现在它突然
we're thinking about it I cleared the cache on my phone and I opened the deck up and I could not find it I knew it was there eventually I opened it up my browser and I search for it in the browser and like the first time gives me an error in the second time then it pops up and now it's like suddenly
显示为我最新的聊天记录。所以，它在搜索到并找到它之前绝对不在列表中。所以他们有一些基础设施，一些基础设施问题。他们得看看。总之，你想要用 Thrust 的术语来表达。所以
showing up as my latest chat. So, like, it was definitely not there in the list until I searched for it and found it. So they have some infrastructure, some infrastructure issues. They got to look at. Anyways, you wanted things expressed in terms of thrust. So
我在说，在我无法找到聊天记录并被打断之前，做这个作为两遍算法是相当直接的……你没有被打断。你把麦克风交给了我。我知道。我被我在 ChatGPT 上找不到它而打断了。被 ChatGPT 打断了。我被 ChatGPT 无法找到东西的粗鲁打断了。
I was saying, before I was unable to find the chat and was interrupted, that it's fairly straightforward to... You were not interrupted. You handed the microwave I know. I interrupted by my inability to find it on chat. Interrupted by chat GPT. I was interrupted by chat GPT's rudeness of not being able to find things.
做这个作为两遍算法是相当直接的。第一遍，所以我们有一个值的输入，比如想象我们有一个函数，它接受一个值设备向量，一个计数设备向量，然后它接受一些输出迭代器，比方说。我们做一个排他性扫描（exclusive scan），首先，我们创建一些临时存储，叫 offset（偏移量）。那将是值的大小。然后我们把计数的排他性扫描放入这个偏移量数组中。
It's fairly straightforward to do this as a two-passed algorithm. Pass number one, so we've got an input of value, like imagine we have a function that takes a device vector of values, a device vector of counts, and then it takes some output iterator, let's say. And we do an exclusive scan from, first of all, we create some temporary storage called like offset. that's going to be the size of the values. And then we do an exclusive scan of the counts into this offsets array.
然后我们……那些名字起得很好。顺便说一下，那些名字起得很好。我一直在说整数序列，等等，计数和偏移量。非常好的名字。是的。不是我选的名字。
And then we... Those are good names for it. Those are good names for it, by the way. I kept on saying integer sequence, yada, yada, counts and offsets. Very nice names. Yeah. Not names that I picked.
是人工智能选的名字。让我们向统治我们的机器神低头吧。是的，统治我们的机器神，我们甚至找不到两天前的那次聊天记录。未来的机器神。我不认同 Bryce 的观点。我为你服务。
Names that the A I picked. Let us all bow down to the machine gods that rule us. Yeah, the machine gods that rule us where we can't even find a chat. that I had two days ago. Future machine god. I do not share Bryce's opinion. I serve you.
是的，我不为任何人服务。所以一旦你完成了那个排他性扫描，人工智能写的第一个版本，它做了一个归约（reduce）来计算输出的大小，然后它做扫描。是的。在这种情况下，我用类似 STL 的算法编写它，我假设你……
Yeah, I serve no one. So then once you've done that exclusive scan, so the first version of this that the AI wrote, it did a reduce to figure out the size of the output, and then it does the scan. Yeah. In this case, I'm writing this with like an STL-style algorithm where I assume that you're,
为人们重复一遍，因为我们有时会忘记，我们已经做了 250 集了，我们跳过了对我们来说显而易见的事情，但为什么当我们做完扫描后不需要归约呢？因为当你对某物做扫描时，扫描的最后一个元素就是整个序列的和。所以在这个特定情况下，我们编写的版本，我们正在写入一个固定大小的输出。所以当你调用这个游程解码时，你给它一个输出缓冲区，并告诉它有多大。如果解码最终超过了缓冲区，它就停止解码。它永远不会超过末尾。我这样写是因为几乎所有的 C++ 算法都是这样设计的。现在通常它们不接受像已知大小的输出，但通常
repeat for people because we forget sometimes we've been doing this for 250 episodes and we escape by what is obvious to us but why do we not need to reduce when we've done a scan because when you do a scan of something the last element of the scan is the sum of the entire sequence so in this particular case the version that we're writing we are writing to a fixed size output. So when you call this run length decode, you give it an output buffer and you tell it how large it is. And if decoding ends up exceeding the buffer, it just stops decoding. It will never go past the end. And I'm writing it this way because almost all of the C++ algorithms are designed this way. Now typically they don't take an output that's like of a known size, but typically
如果有两个输入，它只会执行操作直到两个输入中较小的一个。现在有几个接受大小输出的算法。这对我来说是最自然的编写方式。我认为它最自然的原因是，如果你有一个固定大小的输出缓冲区，那么你就不想要一个会做额外归约来计算输出大小的算法原语，因为那是浪费。如果你没有固定大小的输出，如果你要分配正确的输出大小，那么你可以在调用原语之前自己做归约。所以我认为这是更基本的事情。
if there's like two inputs, it will only perform operations up until the smallest of the two inputs. And there are a couple that now take sized outputs. And this is just sort of the most natural way to write it for me. The reason why I think it's the most natural is that if you have a fixed sized output buffer, then you don't want an algorithmic primitive that's going to do an extra reduction to count the size of the output because that's wasteful. And if you don't have a fixed size output, if you're going to allocate the correct amount of output size, then you can just do the reduction yourself before you call the primitive. So I think that this is the more fundamental thing.
但总之，你做这个扫描，你得到偏移量，然后你可以做一个 for-each，你遍历并使用那些部分的……扫描后的计数来做，是的，偏移量，来做写入，扩展。所以做两遍是相当直接的，但我当然是单遍算法的爱好者。所以我试图想象如何把它作为一个单遍算法来做。我想我提到了，我上次解释得可能很差，有一个协作内核（cooperative kernel）的概念，
But anyways, you do this scan, you get the offsets, and then you can do a four-ach-in where you go through and you use those partial. the scanned counts to do, yeah, the offsets, to do the right, the expansion. And so it's pretty straightforward to do it in two passes, but I, of course, am a lover of a single-pass algorithm. So I was trying to imagine how to do this as a single-pass algorithm. And I think I mentioned, I explained perhaps poorly last time, that there is this idea of a cooperative kernel,
你有一堆同时并发运行的线程组，它们都可以互相同步，并且你使用这种协作内核来实现类似持久化矩阵乘法（persistent mat mul）的东西。持久化矩阵乘法是一种并行算法，它所做的是加载一个输入矩阵，
where you have a bunch of groups of threads that are running concurrently at the same time, and they can all have a synchronize with each other, and that you use this sort of cooperative kernel to implement something like a persistent mat mall. A persistent mat mall is a parallel algorithm where it's, what it does is it loads in, you know, an input matrix,
或输入矩阵，然后它开始对这些输入矩阵进行矩阵乘法，然后在进行矩阵乘法的同时，它开始加载下一组输入。所以它是持久的，因为它不断地执行矩阵乘法，同时也获取，如果可以的话，预取下一组输入来喂入。这在机器学习流水线中非常常见。人们可以想象拥有一个像这样的持久游程解码内核，你拥有这个并行算法在运行，它获取下一组值和计数对，然后将它们扩展到某个输出，然后它写入，然后它继续这样做，直到耗尽所有输入。你这样写游程解码的原因是，你不知道有多少工作，就像你知道你有多少值，并且你
or input matrices, and then it starts doing a matrix multiplication of those input matrices, and then while it's doing that matrix multiplication, it starts loading in a next set of inputs. So it's persistent in that it is constantly performing matrix multiplications while also fetching, pre-fetching, if you will, the next set of inputs to feed in. This is very common in machine learning pipelines. And one could imagine having a persistent run-length decode kernel like this, where you have this parallel algorithm running, where it is, you know, it fetches the next set of values and count pairs, and then it expands them to some output, and then it writes, and then it continues doing this until it's exhausted all of the inputs. And the reason that you would do this, the reason that you would write the run length you could like this is because you do not know how much work, like you know how many values you have and you
知道你有多少计数，但你不知道那代表多少工作，因为你不知道你会有多少输出元素。所以很难提前进行负载均衡。所以我设想编写一个协作版本，我试图思考关于如何进行负载均衡的不同方案……所以你可以做的是，你可以……你可以做一个扫描来弄清楚，就像我们刚才说的，你可以做一个扫描来弄清楚你要写入位置的偏移量，然后在那之后，你可以决定在那一点进行负载均衡。既然你知道所有东西都将写入输出的什么位置，你可以决定进行负载均衡，这样每个线程都在
know how many accounts you have, but you don't know how much work that represents because you don't know how many output elements you're going to have. And so it's hard to like ahead of time do the load balancing. So I was imagining writing a cooperative version of this and I was trying to think about different schemes for how you could do the um the load balancing um so what you could do is you could um you could have like you could do a scan to figure out like as we just said you can do a scan to figure out the offsets of where you're going to write and then after that you could decide to load balance at that point you could decide now that you know where everything's going to be written in the output you could decide to load balance so that every you know thread is
写入大致相同数量的元素。问题在于局部性问题，因为你已经把值和计数加载到了一组线程中，所以它们在某个地方是局部的。所以如果你在那一点进行负载均衡，它可能比仅仅有负载不平衡但仍然保持局部性更糟糕。然后我开始思考各种其他问题，比如如果你有一些非常极端的负载不平衡怎么办。比如如果你有一个值计数对
writing roughly the same number of elements. The problem with that is locality problem because you've already loaded in the values and counts to some set of threads, and so they're local somewhere. And so if you do load balancing at that point, it may be worse than just having load and balance, but still preserving locality. And then I got thinking about all sorts of other problems, like what if you have some really extreme load in balance. Like what if you've got like one value count pair
比其他的数量级大得多？然后我意识到 CUB 游程解码块游程解码可能坏了，因为我几乎肯定它不能处理计数大小超过它支持的固定窗口的情况。Connor 认为那不是 bug，它确实支持，但我看过代码。我几乎肯定他是错的。然后我有了……
that's like, you know, orders of magnitude larger than the others? And then I realize that the the Cobb run length decode block run length decode is probably broken because I'm almost certain that it doesn't handle the case where the size of the count
我没看过代码，但我很确定它是对的。好吧，那你明天可以去测试一下。或者我明天可以去测试一下。然后我有了这个想法。我在这里写了一些笔记。我有一个关于做自适应事情的想法。我想我设想……
or where the count exceeds the size of the fixed wind that it supports. Connor thinks that it's not a bug and that it does support it, but I've looked at the code. I'm almost certain that he's wrong. And then I had...
自适应的事情，如果你做负载均衡，那么你最终会得到这种自适应的，当你遍历输入序列时，你最终会得到不同的负载均衡方案，就像你有不同数量的不同工作分布，你一次拉入的不同运行次数。
I have not looked at the code, but I'm pretty sure it's right. Okay, then you can go test it tomorrow. Or I can go test it tomorrow. And then I had this thought. I wrote some notes down here. I had this idea about sort of doing an adaptive thing. I guess I imagine the...
然后我有了这个洞察，我写道：如果我们的扫描产生类似于 chunk by（按块划分）的区间会怎样？因为我在我的一个演讲中实现了 chunk by，chunk by 是取一个更大的 N 序列，然后产生一个更小的压缩序列。而且你可以，如果你的 chunk by 在相等性上操作，如果你像 chunk by 一样按相等划分，然后你像 chunk by 一样做唯一化，它有点像游程解码的逆运算。
the adaptive thing if you do the load balancing then you sort of like end up with this like adaptive like as you go through the input sequence you end up with different load balancing schemes like you have different amounts of different distributions of work different numbers of runs that you're pulling in at a time
所以我开始认为这可能与 chunk by 有某种关系，也许 chunk by 实际上有点类似于游程编码，或者也许游程编码是 chunk by 的一种特殊形式。是的，这就是我随机的飞机笔记想法。所以我认为我能想出的最好的单遍算法，将是带有或不带有负载均衡的协作算法。
then I sort of had this insight I wrote what if our scan produces intervals similar to chunk by because I I implement in one of my talks, chunk by, which is chunk by is taking a larger sequence of N and then producing a smaller compressed sequence. And you can, if your chunk by operates on equality, if you're chunk by like, chunks by like equal and then like you do chunk by like unique, it's sort of like the inverse of run length
我不知道是否存在非协作算法，但我认为我在这里有一些想法。Connor 想要麦克风。好吧，很明显 chunk by 是游程解码的构建块。游程解码的第一步字面意思就是对组进行分块。它字面意思是一个，我不知道它是否是……
decode. And so I started thinking that maybe this has some relation to chunk by, and that maybe chunk by is actually kind of similar to run length encoding, or maybe run length encoding is like a specialized form of chunk by. And, yeah, and that's just sort of what my random plain note thoughts are. So I think the best algorithm that would be single pass that I could come up with, would be the cooperative one either with or without load balancing.
解码。所以我开始思考这可能与 chunk by 有关，也许 chunk by 实际上和游程编码（run-length encoding）有点相似，或者说游程编码是 chunk by 的一种特殊形式。是的，这就是我随手记下的一些零散想法。所以我认为我能想到的最好的单遍算法，就是那种带或不带负载均衡的协作式算法。
I don't know that a non-cooperative one exists, but I think I had some ideas here about that. Connor wants the microphone. All right, it is obvious that chunk by is a building block for run-lengthen code. That is literally the first step of run-lengthen code is to chunk the groups. It's literally a, I don't know if it's,
我不知道是否存在非协作式的算法，但我对此有一些想法。Connor 想要麦克风。好吧，很明显 chunk by 是游程编码的构建块。这确实是游程编码的第一步，就是对组进行分块。这简直是，我不知道它是否是，
It's well known in Haskell, but the equivalent of chunk by in Haskell is group. There's a group by algorithm that takes the predicate, but group is a specialization where it's just equal to. So you just call group, and then you take the head, which is the equivalent of the first element, and the length. And that's a run-liflingling code. It's like three functions in Haskell. Anyway, so yes, chunk-by is the very first building block of Ronlanklinglingling code, but I want to take it in a different direction. You lost me, Bryce. right we will take it in a different direction in three minutes
在Haskell中这很常见，但Haskell中与chunk by等价的是group。有一个接受谓词的group by算法，但group是一个特例，它只判断是否相等。所以你只需要调用group，然后取头部，这相当于第一个元素和长度。这就是游程编码。在Haskell中就像三个函数一样。总之，是的，chunk-by是游程编码的第一个构建块，但我想要把它引向不同的方向。Bryce，你把我绕晕了。好吧，我们三分钟后再换个方向。
Bryce would like to respond what if there's a more general form of run-link decode because like yeah I know encode is different well but like run length encode is saying like you like collapse with a specific function like you know of like these things are equal
Bryce想回应一下，如果游程解码有一种更通用的形式会怎样？因为，是的，我知道编码是不同的，但游程编码就像是说，你用一个特定的函数来折叠，比如你知道这些东西是相等的。
collapse from down to a single value right like that's a function you can imagine but but but and and run length decode is saying like take this sequence of value count pairs and expand it with a specific function of like just repeating um but what if what if you could imagine like a generic form of this where it had some different way of doing the expansion where you have like you you have value in maybe not count but like almost like value in like you know a function of a like a function application. Yeah. Like for each value, you're going to
折叠成一个单一的值，对吧？这是一种你可以想象的函数，但游程解码是说，获取这个值-计数对序列，并用特定的函数来扩展它，比如重复。但如果你能想象一种更通用的形式会怎样？它有一种不同的扩展方式，比如你有一个值，可能不是计数，而是像函数应用一样。是的。就像对于每个值，你要
do something to produce some number of values. But I don't know. It's just an interesting thought I had that maybe there's a more general version of run length decode. You're correct. I can already think of it. The same way that there is a take in C++20 and there's a take while. Take just takes an integer
做点什么来产生一定数量的值。但我不知道。这只是我产生的一个有趣的想法，也许存在更通用的游程解码版本。你是对的。我已经想到了。就像C++20中有take和take while一样。take只接受一个整数，
and take while takes a unary predicate. If you want to invert that, you could do the same thing. So run length decode takes an integer. you could also design it so that run-length decode takes a predicate. And so it decodes until it satisfies that predicate. And so you can always implement the integer version in terms of the unitary predicate version
而take while接受一个一元谓词。如果你想反转它，你可以做同样的事情。所以游程解码接受一个整数，你也可以把它设计成接受一个谓词。这样它就会一直解码直到满足该谓词。所以你总是可以用一元谓词版本来实现整数版本，
where as long as the current length or count is less than a certain amount. I was thinking maybe even more generic than that where it might decode different values. It can be some kind of, yeah, like expansion function that ends after something. I mean, that's true. All right, now it's been three minutes. Now I'm going to take in a different direction.
只要当前的长度或计数小于某个量。我在想，也许比这更通用，它可能会解码不同的值。它可以是某种在某事之后结束的扩展函数。我的意思是，那是真的。好了，现在三分钟过去了。现在我要换个方向了。
We got to break down what the category of algorithms are. Because we first, I mean, I was talking about thrust. And also, too, I said five kernels. I whipped out the implementation. One of them is an unnecessary fill. And one of them is an unnecessary copy. So the scan, scatter scan algorithm is three kernels. That's what it is in thrust.
我们需要分析这些算法属于什么类别。因为首先，我是指我在谈论Thrust。而且，我也说了五个内核。我拿出了实现方案。其中一个是没必要的填充，另一个是没必要的复制。所以扫描，散布扫描算法是三个内核。在Thrust中就是这样。
Bryce is saying it's two if you just do a four each after a scan. I squint my eyes and I twist my head and I think maybe that way. works, but I'm not entirely convinced because I'm using a scan, and a scan typically can't be replaced by a four each. Well, I don't know so many of two scans. Maybe you don't. But anyways, we'll come back to that later. We're pausing, and we're talking about what are the categories?
Bryce说如果你在扫描之后只做一个for each，那就是两个。我眯起眼睛，歪着头想，也许那样行得通，但我并不完全信服，因为我正在使用扫描，而扫描通常不能被for each取代。好吧，我不知道那么多扫描。也许你不需要。但无论如何，我们稍后再回来讨论这个问题。我们先暂停一下，讨论一下这些类别是什么？
Because you drop down from talking about thrust and then started talking about like a block aware. So, like, what are the, what's your mental model for the taxonomy of algorithms? Be sure to check these show notes, either in your podcast app or at ADSP thepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode as well as a link to a get-up discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast.
因为你从谈论Thrust转而开始谈论块感知。那么，你对算法分类的思维模型是什么？请务必查看这些节目笔记，无论是在你的播客应用中还是在ADSP thepodcast.com上，获取我们今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个GitHub讨论的链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。我们希望你喜欢并祝你有美好的一天。低质量，高数量。这就是我们播客的标语。
It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那不是标语。我们的标语是带有信息点缀的混乱。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。